[Musique]
eh bien les Américains continuent maintenant c'est une
semi-fiction c'est Americana c'est
peut-être encore plus facile ver la maison Blanca
Donald Trump les picomètres ont jamais
organisé un studio a dit pli ou
m'a appris que les repères Lachine la clé de la machine D n'est
qu'un  faux simple alors en a-t-il un c'est un
véritable échec eh bien il y a eu beaucoup
de je dirais la politisation et les guider
dans la vie ce n'est pas une bonne chose
les livres de vêtements je ne le fais jamais
si c'est correctement dirigé la colère
contre la démocratie ne le faites pas  le
renvoyer c'est sûr
- Kevin zombie cher Cardinal trivanti le
pathos c'est les lacunes de la population d'
homogène une roue de contrôle pas de page avec
Alex tourne ouais ne donne pas le pouvoir à la
plaque de fond ou pas si gentil todo
Diavel un professeur appli mobile lézard
adulte maladroitement de la mer  c'est à titre préventif
quelques pâturages coq Moïse
original
tu ne peux jamais savoir ce que tu peux
ramener à la chimie ça n'imite pas
un artiste il faut un charlatan
légitime Gemma compagnon polic  y ne
vendez pas sur imaginez est-ce que les gens mouillés tous les jours
pacifistes propre évolution travaillaient sur 3d hé
réponse de Polly une lishchyna hépatique
dit pasteur d'un accusateur de Pakeha Belka Donald
Trump
Lucinda ici le masque scara's Dominique
une famille plus possible
président de la société dosa coquille
bien il le fait  veut punir la
Chine Je veux dire, tu sais que c'est plus
beau dès que tu sais
[Musique]
c'est correct
Susanna clique sur vues mr.  mari
évocateur ignorer l'échange sur les lacs
transformer votre gâchis